1990. Alors que l'Occident part en croisade et édifie des cathédrales, l'Asie va se trouver remodelée par les chevauchés des Mongols de Jajis Khan.
Camp ici !
Petain que ramasse les enfants mêlés à l'herbe séchée est le seul combustible utilisé en cette route contrée.
Tu veux les tailles de joutes ?
Oui, valeureux Temujin. Trouvera leur camp à trois jours de cheval. Ils t'accompagneront.
Merci bien, mes amis !
Mais non, c'est traître !
Oui, c'est ainsi avec une poignée d'hommes que commence l'épopée de Temujin.
Ce jeune chef va connaître un destin fabuleux et sous le nom de Gengis Khan, bâtir un des plus vastes empires de l'histoire.
Mme Kahn en 1200, il conquiert la Mongolie et la Sibérie en 1207, le Tibet en 1209, la Chine est envahie en 1211, le Kazakhstan en 1218.
En 1220, c'est la guerre contre le Khorasan qui a fait offense aux Mongols et refuse réparation.
Gengis Khan rassemble 200 000 cavaliers et on en arme davantage du côté musulman.
L'époque en 1214, pour la grande victoire de Bouvines, les chevaliers français ne sont qu'un millier.
Il n'est pas de plus grande joie pour un homme que de tailler en pièces ses ennemis,
les chasser devant soi, s'approprier leurs biens,
voir en larmes ceux qui leur sont chers,
prendre dans ses bras leurs femmes et leurs filles.
La profession de foi de Gingis Khan.
Lorsqu'il meurt à 65 ans, d'une chute de cheval, dit-on, son empire est immense.
Il sera encore agrandi par ses fils et petits-fils,
dont le plus éminent sera Kubilai,
ce petit garçon justement auquel le moribond donne sa bénédiction.
Et si le pape veut bien m'envoyer six hommes sages de votre foi chrétienne,
Instruit dans les sept arts, et sachant bien débattre et prouver clairement aux idolâtres que la foi du Christ est la meilleure,
que toutes les autres lois sont mauvaises et fausses,
moi, le grand Khan, et tous ceux sur qui je détiens le pouvoir, nous deviendrons chrétiens et hommes-liges de l'église.
Voilà le message dont le grand Khan, Kubilay, avait chargé les frères Polo, prospères marchands de Venise,
quand ils l'ont quitté voilà deux ans.
Ils retournent donc vers lui.
Leur fils et neveu Marco les accompagnent.
Nous allons nous rendre à Sipango et Kathe, mais avant nous ferons escale à Acre.
Nous devons voir le pape Grégoire de plaisance.
Voici Acre, mes amis. Je suis désolé, mais il va falloir nous séparer.
Tu ne crois pas que vous pourriez avoir besoin d'un garçon fort comme lui ?
Et d'un sujet brillant comme mon copain ?
Attendez un moment.
Vous pourrez peut-être emmener avec nous ces deux braves garçons. Ils peuvent nous être utiles.
C'est une bonne idée, Marco. Tes amis seront du voyage.
Merci, père. Je vais leur dire. Vous serez des nôtres, les amis.
Hourra !
Très Saint-Père, le grand canne auquel nous allons rendre visite
apprécierait que des émissaires mandatés par sa sainteté lui portent témoignages de l'Occident et de la chrétienté.
Cette marque de respect va le prédisposer en faveur de notre cause.
Voilà qui fera l'affaire, mon fils.
Mais Saint-Père...
Oui, voilà les saintes huiles.
Mais il nous faudrait aussi des ambassadeurs, tels que ces vénérables frères.
Hein ?
C'est vrai, je vous accorde ces dollars.
Mais vous ne pensez pas que nous pourrions vous être beaucoup plus utiles ici, Saint-Père ?
Ça vous convient ?
Ben, c'est-à-dire, j'avais espéré qu'il y en aurait au moins six.
Oh, mais vous n'y pensez pas si, frère, il n'en est pas question !
Ben alors, peut-être si...
Non, non !
Les mêmes quatre ?
J'ai dit non !
Enfin, je peux compter sur deux.
Je n'ai qu'une parole !
Va pour deux !
Répète que frère Nicolas de Vicence est frère Guillaume de Triple !
Ben, d'où est-il passé ?
Frère Guillaume !
Je vais descendre tout de suite sur la Terre !
Nul ne peut monter sur ma permission !
Notre père qui est aux cieux, protégez-moi.
Écoutez, on vient !
Vous êtes des hommes du Sultan du Caire qui vient nous envahir ?
Ah, du tout !
Nous arrivons de Venise, tenez !
Hé hé hé !
Viens-vous de cette bourse d'or ?
Quoi se contenter de cette petite bourse quand on peut avoir tout ce qu'il possède ?
Et de plus, qu'est-ce qui nous empêche de les faire prisonniers et de les revendre comme esclaves ?
Attachez ces étrangers !
C'est une brillante mission si on reste en vie.
Nous préférons...
Mais les ordres de sa paire !
Ne nous en veuillez pas, mais nous ne sommes pas faits pour les voyages.
Comme vous voulez.
Allez, mes frères.
Et nous prierons pour vous.
Attendez, que Dieu vous garde.
Et vous aussi, amen !
Caravane de nos amis s'avance au Moyen-Orient.
Quand un jour...
Voyez !
Je te knowe !
Allons, ne nous attardons pas trop.
Pour trasse !
T'auras un effort et cette fois, ils vont voir de quel bois je me chante !
Un autre jour à Mossoul...
À un moment, qu'est-ce que c'est que ce liquide noir dans les jarres ?
Du pétrole.
Nos amis vont atteindre le baltage.
Un peu qu'on les rattrape et vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir !
D'où un petit voilier va les mener jusqu'au port d'Hormuz sur le golfe Persique.
Les rattrape, ils peuvent pas aller plus loin !
Je peux mettre à votre disposition ce magnifique bateau.
Je vous le garantis, étrangers.
Je me demande s'il est vraiment solide.
Vous, Rakaï, vous n'auriez pas vu des gens qui ressemblent à ça ?
Non, non, non.
Si jamais on te demande après nous, tu dis qu'on est partis en mer.
Pas vu ceux-là.
Ils sont partis en mer de là-bas, vous les voyez ?
Alors nous les tenons cette fois.
Allez, tu es en vitesse !
Remonte vers le Khorasan, se lève un vent qui masque les embûches de la route.
Cette fois, nous les tenons !
Ces formalités réglées, nos amis peuvent tranquillement poursuivre leur chemin
jusqu'aux premières pentes de l'un de nos couches.
La traversée sera pénible, pénible, périlleuse.
Pas important que celle du désert de Gobi, aux redoutables tempêtes de sable.
Le désert traversé, Polo et les siens vont atteindre la ville de Chamoule,
dont les habitants sont réputés pour leur sens de l'hospitalité.
Andi, fuyons !
Retrait !
Les hommes même les plus féroces ont aussi parfois besoin de repos.
J'ai fait le bon sang, il doit encore vous échapper !
C'est l'automne, la transhumance.
Poussant devant elle leur troupeau, les tribus mongoles descendent des hauts plateaux.
Ne dirait-on pas que c'est là ?
Et celui-là, ne serait-ce pas notre gros ami ?
Curieuse race, c'est mon lol.
La vie s'organise au campement.
Espèce de sale baisse !
Les chasseurs vont traquer le loup, au camp, la vie quotidienne va suivre son cours.
Non, non !
Quoi, tu connais la loi ?
Si le voleur peut se racheter et donner neuf fois autant que ce qu'il a pris, il sera absourde.
Dis donc, tu n'as rien d'autre à nous offrir ?
Sinon, il recevra sept coups de bâton.
37, jusqu'à 107, selon le mal qu'il aura fait.
L'un des robins cheval, il devra perdre la vie.
Et on le tranchera au milieu du corps avec une épée.
C'est bien que nos poursuivants ont disparu.
- Alors là, on va s'amuser. - Il va voir !
...mais de votre visite m'a chargé de vous escorter et de vous prêter aide et assistance.
Nous vous suivons avec joie jusqu'au palais du Grand Kubilay.
Dernière boucle du fleuve Jaune, et au bout, Pékin, le but.
Voilà près de quatre années que dure le voyage des polos.
- Salut !
L'empereur est le plus puissant souverain qui ait existé depuis Adam et jusqu'à ce jour.
De belles façons, ni petit ni grand, il est charnu, très bien taillé dans tous ses membres,
son visage est blanc et vermeil, les yeux noirs, le nez bien fait.
Il a quatre femmes qu'il tient pour ses épouses légitimes.
Aussi quelques centaines de concubines.
Sachez qu'il fait tenir là un très grand hara de juments toutes blanches,
sans tâche aucune, au nombre de plus de dix mille.
Boit ainsi que ceux de son lignage le lait de ses juments que personne d'autre ne peut boire.
Le jour brille sur les fils du ciel !
Notre souverain tout-puissant a reçu des visiteurs étrangers venus de l'autre bout du monde !
Il est temps de...
Garry ?
Elle vous plaît ?
Je peux l'essayer ?
Bien sûr !
Vous avez quelque chose dans ma taille ?
Oui, honorable étranger, attendez !
Bien, parfait !
Et moi ?
Je n'en ai qu'une sur moi.
Ah, ça sera très bien comme ça.
Je veux la plus belle tunique que tu possèdes.
Je suis votre humble serviteur.
C'est très splendissant, honorable seigneur, comme l'étoile du matin.
Combien en veux-tu ?
Euh, euh, trois pièces.
Eh bien, tu en auras cinq.
Oh.
Cette mission vous permettra de prouver vos qualités.
Sachez-vous en montrer digne.
Nos amis se rendent donc auprès du général qui assiège la ville de Shang-Fu.
Regardez ces remparts, nobles étrangers.
Tous nos assauts s'y sont brisés.
Mes hommes sont épuisés par les combats.
Je ne sais vraiment pas ce qu'on pourrait faire.
Il me semble qu'on pourrait essayer ces fameuses catapultes dont on nous avait parlé.
Il advint que Marco apprit fort rapidement les mœurs des tartares,
leur langue, à en écrire les caractères,
se montrant avisé et prudent en toute matière.
Lorsqu'il revenait, Marco racontait à l'empereur
toutes les choses neuves et étranges qu'il avait vues.
Il le faisait d'une manière agréable et intelligente
et lui exposait les solutions qu'il avait apportées.
Celui-ci s'en réjouissait fort et lui témoigna grande amitié et grande faveur.
Les uns vénère Jésus, les autres Mahomet, d'autres le Bouddha, moi je leur demande à tous de me protéger, c'est plus sûr.
Voici ta nouvelle mission, viens.
A vos ordres, grand Kublai.
De mission en mission, les années vont passer.
Il a 17 ans que nos amis sont au service de Kublai.
Ils voudraient bien rentrer chez eux, mais le grand Khan, qui leur est très attaché, s'y oppose.
Ils commencent à perdre l'espoir de revoir leur patrie quand un jour, trois barons venus de la lointaine Perse arrivent à la cour.
Leur seigneur désire que l'empereur lui accorde une nouvelle épouse, car la sienne est morte.
C'est charmant !
Les polos pourraient-ils nous raccompagner chez nous ?
Ce sont des voyageurs avisés.
Nous vous en serions infiniment reconnaissants.
Le maître ayant pour les latins grande considération
était fort peu enclin à les laisser partir.
Enfin, il se laissait affléchir
et leur rejoignit d'accompagner les barons et la jeune princesse.
Et force lui fut de prendre de nouveaux conseillers.
Il y a vraiment pas de choses à faire.
Le grand cain remit à nos amis des laissés-passés,
des messages pour le roi de la chrétienté
et eu treize bateaux pour les mener à bon port.
Pour le voyage qui les attendait, ça n'allait pas être de trop.
Le voyage de retour a duré trois ans.
Et à voir dans quel état se trouvent nos amis,
nous comprenons sans peine que ce ne fut pas là une promenade de tout repos.
Boucher à l'écurie !
À l'écurie.
Demain, devant toute la famille réunie,
24 ans, les polos ont quitté leur maison.
Le palais du Grand Cannes.
La salle en est si vaste que six mille personnes pourraient y manger à l'aise.
Et il y a tant de chambres que nul n'a jamais pu les compter.
Tout cela est si beau et si grand que les mots me manquent pour le décrire.
Je crois que personne au monde ne pourrait mieux faire.
Qu'en dites-vous ?
C'est qui lui ?
Les miséreux, les vieillards, les orphelins sont logés par le grand canne et on leur distribue du pain chaud.
Dans la province de Zardendan, quand les femmes ont enfanté, tout aussitôt elles se lèvent et vont à leur travail.
Le mari se met au lit, tient l'enfant avec lui et reste ainsi 40 jours pendant lesquels parents et amis viennent le féliciter.
C'est insensé !
Mais ce n'est pas tout, il y a encore plus fort.
Le grand seigneur fait récolter la moelle du murier, qu'on trouve entre le bois de l'arbre et son écosse.
De cela, on fait un papier tout noir et on le découpe.
Le moindre de ces papiers vaut un demi-denier.
Plus grand, il vaut un besan d'or, et ainsi de suite, jusqu'à dix besan.
Tous ces papiers sont scellés au seau du seigneur,
et il en fait une si grande quantité qu'elle paierait tous les joyaux du monde,
même les plus exceptionnels que puissent imaginer les plus puissants souverains de notre planète.
Et voilà pourquoi j'affirme que son trésor est sans fin.
le monde entier finira par lui appartenir.
Dans la capitale, il arrive plus d'objets précieux que dans mille autres villes au monde.
De soie seulement, il en vient chaque jour plus de mille chartées.
Personne donc ne songe à s'habiller d'autre chose que des soies les plus rares.
Mais ce chenome exagère vraiment !
Dans toute la province de Cathay, il y a une sorte de pierre noire qu'on tire des montagnes.
Ces pierres brûlent comme des bûches et maintiennent le feu de telle sorte
que si vous les allumez la nuit, vous les retrouvez encore allumés le lendemain matin.
Oh, c'est amusant !
Il y a un fleuve qui est le plus grand du monde et que sillonne quinze mille bateaux.
Et à Angcheu, la capitale qu'il traverse, on peut admirer douze mille ponts de pierre,
si haut que par-dessous pourraient passer toute voile dehors,
les plus grands navires que la flotte vénitienne ait jamais possédé.
J'ajoute que cette merveilleuse cité est entièrement bâtie sur l'eau.
Il suffit, monsieur Milione !
1298, Venise est en guerre avec Gênes, cité rivale.
Près de l'île de Curzola, sur un bateau véhicule.
Ils sont nombreux, bien armés. Le combat sera difficile.
À vos postes, pariez au combat !
Et malgré les efforts des nôtres,
Mes amis !
Padron Marco !
Jamais homme fut-il chrétien, sarrasin, tartare ou païen,
n'a voyagé de par le monde autant que le fils noble et illustre citoyen de Venise,
Messire Marco Polo.
Malgré quelques erreurs, quelques légendes,
l'Occident va connaître pour la première fois
une description réelle de cet Extrême-Orient inconnu jusqu'alors.
Et deux siècles plus tard, Christophe Colomb va partir vers l'Ouest
à la recherche de cette cathée, de ces indes décrites par Marco Polo,
et découvrir l'Amérique.